(upbeat guitar music)
- This menorah is a real Texas menorah.
Most people who know much about menorahs
don't know anything about armadillos.
And the people who do
know about armadillos
certainly don't know
anything about menorahs.
So it's very unusual to
find people like myself
that know about menorahs and armadillos.
- I'm Nico Tortorella.
I'm an actor, an activist
and a firm believer that
our differences actually make us stronger.
I'm on a journey with
IKEA to meet real people
and discover the diverse
and spectacular ways
they celebrate the holidays.
Maybe you celebrate the holidays
with traditional food and decorations;
or, maybe you celebrate
them with your bandmates
and a guitar in hand,
like country music legend Kinky Friedman.
- Hi, this is Kinky
Friedman, and I write songs.
(melancholy acoustic guitar)
- [Nico] What would you say
your greatest achievement has been?
- Well, playing the Grand Ole Opry.
- Oh, yeah?
What year was that?
- '73.
And, um, that's where I was introduced as
the first full-blooded Jew to ever appear
on the Grand Ole Opry stage.
- Wow.
- Yeah,I loved it.
Years later I discover that
Nelson Mandela had smuggled
tape cassettes in his
prison cell in Robben Island
and one of them was Sold
American, my record.
I never dreamed that Nelson
Mandela would be listening.
- Kinky celebrates the holidays
in a very non-traditional way.
He gets his chosen family together:
his bandmates, people in
his community, his friends.
They get together, and they play music.
(laughing)
♪ Nagila hava, nagila hava. ♪
Kinky's Jewishness made him stand out,
gave him this real powerful
angle to write from.
He uses this common bond of
music to spread tradition.
- An important thing
about being Jewish is that
you are definitely on
the outside looking in.
But that's where the
best material comes from,
if you're an author of
any kind or a songwriter
or just a human being.
That's where you more clearly
see what life is all about.
♪ Well, the only whole
heart is a broken one. ♪
♪ And the only true
love an unspoken one. ♪
One, two, three.
- One, two, three.
(howls)
Wow.
(upbeat acoustic guitar)
In years past, Kinky has
embarked on Hanukkah tours.
This year, we had a small concert
with some locals at the ranch.
♪ - That I used to know. ♪
♪ Now it's me and a three-legged
dog named Freedom. ♪
- As unique as Kinky is, his
interpretation of Hanukkah
is as pure as gold.
And maybe he doesn't celebrate
it the way you see on TV.
Maybe those are the things
that make his tradition so special.
♪ -There ain't no quit
in either one of us. ♪
(defiant acoustic guitar)
(crowd applauds)